he's the author of The New York Times
bestseller Trump's America the truth
about our nation's great comeback former
Speaker of the House Fox News
contributor Newt Gingrich in every case
you have inconsistencies now tonight was
glaring in this avenatti client of his
and no corroboration for the very people
that they said would corroborate yes now
that's a problem I'll take you off for
thirty seconds away from this all of us
should recognize in the last 24 hours
President Trump is won an enormous
victory with Canada and Mexico in the
middle of all this noise it's at Point
big things are happening to create lots
of new jobs to keep the economy going
because the president's delivery is
getting results
I just want do that not insignificant
asleep
this to me is a real threat one of the
foundational principles that we share
all of us this is why I say it's not
Republican or never but here's what I
don't understand okay and you know I've
been at this a long time that a little
bit they talked about this deal that
Koons might Koontz gave up nothing I
mean Republicans sometimes have this de
passion for being stupid think got
nothing out of Coons nothing
so Coons plays this game oh we're really
bipartisan let me see how I can rip you
off again and Republicans said oh yeah
would you please rip me off a little bit
because I feel so much better when you
take advantage I mean people that
there's a reason people get fed up with
this stuff Lindsey Graham will you had
on a while ago is the most effective guy
on the Judiciary Committee told the
truth and I think we have the chimeric
and people got to stand up and say they
don't want a country that is dominated
by these kind of people and I think it's
a really serious threat what did you
think of Lindsay's idea that if they
fall a vote short this should be a
referendum election then on this issue
and the president would Rinat Nate maybe
perhaps it's a good really good for this
region the Alabama senator who is
supposedly not a liberal has come out
and is gonna vote with the left you have
Donnelly representing the vice
president's home state is going to vote
with the left you're probably going to
have hide camp in a state which
Republicans are carried
sixteen out of the last 17 presidential
campaigns it's probably going to vote
with the left and you had tester in the
state we carried 15 out of 17 didn't
mention well my name mentions gonna vote
for Cavanaugh well it but it is I'll
tell you what if Manchin doesn't vote
for Cavanaugh and they definitely should
bring Cavanaugh back up because after
the election Manchin will have
disappeared yeah
you know one of the problems we've
gotten too used to and I bring this I
warn this audience my radio audience
every two or four years racist sexist
misogynist homophobe xenophobe
islamaphobe dirty air water killed
children killed grandma thrown over the
cliff I watched you go through this I I
was there I saw it all but there's a
certain embracing of slander now where
it doesn't matter it doesn't it doesn't
matter whose family is hearing this it
doesn't matter what they're saying score
points with their crazed friends the
more vicious you are the more your
friends celebrate you the nastier you
are the more your friend celebrates you
I mean that's the people interest and
we're a moment this election this fall
is about two Americas it's about an
America that thinks bullying you in a
restaurant bullying you in an elevator
harassing you destroying you smearing
you shaming you in front of your
children is fine because they're morally
pure so I see I never hear a single
positive agenda item that's going to
benefit the American people from the
Democrats this is what I hear that they
want to impeach Trump they want endless
investigations they want to keep Obama
care which has been a disaster they want
to get rid ice open borders and they
want the crumbs back they want the tax
cuts back that they call crumbs but
there's such crumbs they want it back
how do Republicans well defeat history
in the sense that it's only happened
three times in the last hundred years
party gets power in the white house and
then win seats or holds on to power in
the midterms well the same reason the
same way we won in 16 we get more votes
where it matters I mean the objective
fact is and I'm gonna go out on a limb
and I did this with you in 16 let me go
out on a limb here
I think election night this year
we'll be worse for liberals than 2016 I
think their state of shock this is the
Democratic Party now for me for example
Gavin Newsom the cannon for governor
California wants to have government-run
health care to pay for health care for
illegal immigrants million thing about
Eagle alerts that that's this year but
when the word goes out across the planet
go to California get free health care
how many people every person who gets
sick on the planet is gonna be told gift
to California they want to take care of
you well I don't think that I think
those kind of policies are so
unsustainable Bob Menendez is in a two
point New Jersey and by the way the most
important recent indicator which to
leave media doesn't to look at is we
want a seat in South Texas we've not had
a hundred and thirty nine years it's 63
percent Hispanic and the minute they
learned that the Democrats favorite tax
paid abortion they just left they said
we're not with you if this doesn't
awaken the base of the conservative
movement Republican Party Trump
supporters I don't know what will
but it is waking up I think I had a
friend of MIT say to me today they had
never seen as many conservatives as
angry as they are now because it's when
you look at Cavanaugh and you look at
his two daughters and you look at his
wife and you think these thirty sad
human beings are willing to do this to
this family without any corroboration at
all right scary mr. speaker good to see
always great to be in your hometown the
swamp well I guess now Italy would be
your hometown the Holy See but thank you